-OK, welcome back.
So for those of you who
have come in recently,
this is our inaugural event of
the next in science program.
The idea is, at least
from my perspective,
that a lot of the interesting
new science in emerging areas
come when we look
across disciplines,
when there's interdisciplinary
work being done.
And typically early
career scientists
are the ones that are
leading the charge.
So the philosophy was to bring
in early career scientists
to talk to a broad
audience, and each other,
for that matter, to help
enlighten us at Harvard
and the general public
about what might be
the new frontiers of science.
So we had two speakers in the
first session, one talking
about living
approaches to building
defensible shorelines and
one about sound communication
between whales and fish.
And now we're turning to a talk
on the origins of Earth's water
by Lydia Hallis who is
a Marie Curie research
fellow at the School
of Geographical
and earth sciences at the
University of Glasgow.
And she did post doctoral work
at the University of Hawaii
at Manoa and did her doctoral
work at the Natural History
Museum in London.
And before the break, we were
talking about the question,
how do we know that?
And this is one of these
issues where I frequently
come across things that I was
taught as a boy in science
class and I just, sort
of, repeated it verbatim
as if it's always true, but
not asking the question,
how do we really
know what it is?
And so one of the interesting
things for me was I
came across an article
she had published
on the origins of
water on Earth.
And I had seen repeated
many, many times that it
was from comets
smashing into the Earth
and that's where all
the water came from
and I took that as an article of
faith until I read her article.
And so I'm fascinated to
actually see this in person
and get asked
questions so, Lydia.
-Hi.
Afternoon, everybody.
Yes, so now for something
completely different.
I'm going to be talking about
where Earth's water actually
came from.
This is not a study
that I've done on my own
in any way, shape or form.
I worked at the University
of Hawaii NASA Astrobiology
Institute for four years before
I came to Glasgow in 2014.
And that institute had been
set up for 10 years prior
to me even arriving.
And they had this big
question to answer, where
did Earth's water come from?
And, really, it was all
about solar system formation,
and looking at water on
different planetary bodies,
and trying to
figure out why Earth
is this really habitable and
nice place for us to live.
So, the big questions were
did Earth form with water,
or was water added later?
So this is the
cometary argument.
Did we get our water
from comets that
are generated in the
outer solar system
and come in and collide
with the early Earth?
Or did Earth form wets
from building blocks
that contained water initially?
These could have been water
which asteroids, for example.
Where did these building blocks
come from, is another question.
So, were they are
likely to be water rich?
Where abouts in the solar
system did they come from?
The outer solar system?
The inner solar system?
Is our material that
the Earth is made from
formed close to
home, or did it come
in from the outer solar system
because of the chaotic nature
of the early solar system?
How much water
does Earth contain?
That seems like a
really simple question
because it's very
easy for us to add
up the volume of the
oceans on the surface,
and the volume of the
rivers and the lakes,
and the amount of water
that's in the atmosphere
and say this is how
much water is contained.
It's counter-intuitive
as a non-geologist, which
I assume a lot of you are,
to think that rocks actually
contain a lot of water.
But there's more water present
beneath the Earth's surface
by far than there is present
on the surface of the Earth
and in the atmosphere.
We don't know very much
about how much that
is, there are estimates that
vary between something like six
oceans worth of water
beneath our feet to,
I think it goes to
about 20 at the moment,
but it varies all the time.
And the last question
was, well, now
the last question is does
Earth have more water
than other terrestrial planets?
I think when the
Institute was first
set up that question
would have been
why does Earth have more water
than the other terrestrial
planets.
But the more and more we looked
into the amount of water that
can be present in
the deep Earth,
the more we realized that that
might not actually be true
and that Earth and the
other terrestrial planets
may have very similar
amounts of water.
OK, so all of
these questions can
be answered, or at
least in part answered,
by the study of hydrogen isotope
ratios and water abundancies
in Earth's primitive mantle.
So this would be a area in the
deep Earth that is chemically
the same as the material that
the Earth formed from 4 and 1/2
billion years ago.
Nothing's happened to
it, nothing has changed,
no surface processes have
affected this material.
We call it primitive mantle.
So this is where I have to get
into hydrogen isotope ratios.
Please don't fall
asleep, because it
does get quite geochemical,
but I'll try and, sort of,
reduce most of the geochemistry.
So there are two types of
hydrogen, the two flavors
of hydrogen. The normal
hydrogen isotope has
an atomic mass of one.
That's normal hydrogen
that's in the air, in water,
and most of the time on Earth.
Then there's the
other hydrogen isotope
which we call deuterium.
So the symbol for
it is D. It just
has an extra neutron
in its atomic nucleus.
So it has an atomic mass of two.
Comparing the D and H ratio
of different planetary bodies
can indicate the
origin of these bodies.
For example, whether they came
from the inner solar system,
or whether they came from
the outer solar system.
And in very general
terms, we can explain this
if we look at how the
solar system formed.
So before the sun
formed, we have what's
called the molecular cloud.
And this is all of
the dust and gas
that later went on to form
the planets and the sun.
In this molecular cloud there
is water already as a molecule.
And the water is
very deuterium rich,
so it has a lot of the
heavier hydrogen isotope.
When the sun forms, because the
inner solar system becomes hot,
this water interacts with
molecular hydrogen, so hydrogen
gas, H2, which has
a low DH ratio.
So that means it has a lot of
the lighter hydrogen isotope.
And this interaction
means that the water then
becomes rich in the
lighter hydrogen isotope,
it has a low DH ratio.
In the outer solar
system, because it's still
cold in this region of the
outer disk, in this area here,
you don't get that reaction.
Because it's cold, it's
really cold out there.
So the reaction either doesn't
happen, or it's very sluggish.
So not much of the water
of the molecular cloud
will interact with hydrogen gas.
Therefore, you get the DH
ratio of the molecular cloud
in the outer solar
system still to this day.
Which means that
right now, in general,
the closer that you are to the
sun, the lower the DH ratio,
so the more light
hydrogen you have.
The further out you go,
the more the deuterium
you have, so the
higher the DH ratio.
OK, in terms of notation, to
make that a little bit simpler,
we use delta D. So we stop
talking about DH ratios
and we just use
units of delta D.
To make things simple we
standardize everything
to Earth's ocean water.
So Vienna Standard
Mean Ocean Water there,
which is VSMOW we call it,
has a delta D value of zero.
And everything is
compared to ocean water.
So anything with a
positive delta D value
is richer in deuterium
than ocean water.
And anything with a
negative delta D value
is richer in the lighter
hydrogen isotope.
So it's poorer in deuterium.
So, for example, on
Earth ice and rocks
tend to have negative
delta D values
because they preferentially
incorporate the lighter
hydrogen isotope.
This gets a little
bit more complicated
because hydrogen isn't a
normal isotopic system.
Deuterium has twice the
atomic mass of hydrogen,
and that doesn't happen in
any other isotopic system.
It means that the mass
difference between the two
isotopes is very large, so
you get a very large effect
when you melt something,
when you freeze something,
or when you evaporate something.
They separate from
each other very easily.
So it means that when
you freeze something
you can get a preferential
incorporation of the lighter
hydrogen isotopes, but also
when you evaporate water
from the oceans
into the atmosphere
you also get the preferential
incorporation of the lighter
hydrogen isotope.
Because it's lighter so
it evaporates easier,
so you get more of
the lighter hydrogen
isotope in the atmosphere.
To complicate
matters further, we
have something called
genes or thermal escape
in the upper layers
of our atmosphere.
This happens on all
planetary bodies.
And what it means is that
because the lighter hydrogen
isotope is only half
the mass of deuterium,
it takes much less
energy for that atom
to reach it's escape velocity.
So when high energy particles
come into the upper atmosphere
such as solar wind,
cosmic rays, and they
hit one of these atoms, the
lighter hydrogen isotope
can much easier be blasted
off and lost to space
than deuterium.
And so what happens
over geological time,
over these 4 and 1/2 billion
years the Earth has been
around, is that
we preferentially
lose the hydrogen
isotope and the DH
ratio will go up over time.
So this is really, really
well demonstrated by Mars.
So I'm going to move away
from the Earth for a second.
Mars' atmosphere is very,
very deuterium enriched.
And the reason for
that is because Earth
has a magnetic field, a
global magnetic field, that
protects us from a lot of
the radiation from the sun
and a lot of the solar wind
stripping that would otherwise
occur.
Mars did have a global
magnetic field until around 4
billion years ago, and then the
global magnetic field stopped.
That's another question
as to why that happened.
But it disappeared of
four billion years.
And since then
Mars' atmosphere has
been exposed to the
solar wind, and it's
been slowly stripped away.
Deuterium and hydrogen
have been stripped away
at different rates.
And so we have this
value of plus 2000
to plus 8000 in Mars' atmosphere
at the moment because deuterium
has been left behind and
the lighter hydrogen isotope
has been preferentially
stripped away.
Just because Earth
has a magnetic field
doesn't mean this hasn't
happened on Earth,
it just means the
process isn't so extreme.
So the bottom line is
changes in the DH ratio
via atmospheric and
surface processes
mean we can't rely
on any surface
water, or any
upper mantle water,
really, on Earth to give us
the original hydrogen isotope
ratio of Earth.
We must go deeper
into the mantle.
So, as I just mentioned,
Earth is complicated
because we do have
plate tectonics.
No other body in the solar
system has plate tectonics.
On Mars you have a static crust.
So the atmosphere and the
mantle are completely separated.
And if you measure the DH
ratio in a Martian meteorite,
in water trapped in
a Martian meteorite,
it's low, different to
the atmosphere completely.
On Earth, because
you've got this mixing
of subducted plates,
you potentially
have ocean water and
sediment mixing down
into the upper mantle and
possibly parts of the deeper
mantle.
You can't rely on any mantle
material, or any normal rock,
to give you the
original signature,
the primitive hydrogen
isotope signature of Earth.
We have to go even deeper
down than the upper mantle.
Rock samples from
the deepest areas
that are exposed
on the surface are
found in Hawaii,
Iceland, Baffin Island,
all these hot spot
volcano environments.
The Galapagos and
the Canary Islands
are two of the good examples.
And they come from what
are known as plumes,
the hot spots on the surface.
This plume material is thought
to come from the core mantle
boundary.
So this is the core
here, the mantle in red,
and this plume material
comes up all the way
from the core mantle boundary.
So that's thousands
of kilometers.
This material comes up to the
surface, is erupted as lava,
solidifies into rock, and
hopefully traps its chemistry,
the chemistry from down
here, at this surface for us
to go and sample and pick
up and have a look at.
So that is what we aim to do.
The first samples
that we looked up
with from Baffin Island, a
place called Padloping Island.
So this is Padloping
Island, it's
only a few kilometers across,
the cliff edges all along here.
The samples were
collected in 1985
by Professor Don Francis at
McGill University in Montreal.
And they were collected from
this Northern area here.
When he collected
the samples he had
no idea how geochemically
special they were,
but in the interim
years they've been
really intensively studied.
And it's found that
they are actually
quite unique sample set.
For example, they contain the
highest helium isotope ratios
ever measured in
a sample on Earth.
I'm not going to go into
helium isotopic ratios.
But, basically, if you have
a high helium isotope ratio,
it means that your sample
has been undegassed,
has been undisturbed
since the formation
or the beginning of the Earth.
Similarly we have
lead isotopes that
show an ancient
undisturbed mantle source.
So we know that this
source of this plume
has been untouched
by any mantle mixing,
by any mixing of
different sources down
in the deep mantle, for
4.55 to 4.45 billion years.
So that's almost the
age of the Earth.
It's around about the
age that the moon formed
on the Earth, the giant impact.
The other special thing about
these Padloping Island samples
is, because we're trying to
measure hydrogen inside a rock,
we want the hydrogen
to still be in there.
We don't want the lava to
erupt, and degas, and lose
lots of steam as it erupts.
So it needs to be
erupted under pressure.
So these rocks were erupted
around about 60,000 years ago
under water, under seawater,
deep down under the sea.
So they erupted
under pressure, which
means that the gases that are
in those rocks can't escape.
They're trapped.
The things we actually
measured in the samples
were glassy melt inclusions.
So these are electron microscope
images of some of the samples.
These dark gray crystals you can
see here are olivine crystals.
That's a really common
mineral in lots of types
of rock in the ocean crust.
Generally on the Earth olivine
is a very common mineral.
But, the great thing about
olivine is that it does
tend to trap these, what
are called, melt inclusions.
They're basically little,
tiny pockets of lava
that gets trapped as
the crystals forming
and the composition of
that lava is then trapped
as it was before
crystallization.
So you've got a sample
there of the melt
as it came from the deep mantle.
The great thing about
the olivine crystal,
as well, is, as I
mentioned, these samples
have been on the surface
for 60,000 years.
Rain water, ice, at
Baffin Island sea water,
can get to that
glass if it's not
protected by these crystals.
But the crystals are
protecting the glass.
And it's very easy to see
whether an olivine crystal has
been weathered to something
like a clay, in which case
we would avoid it.
These are pristine
olivine samples
that haven't been
weathered at all,
so we know that rainwater
hasn't got into the glass
and contaminated what
we're trying to look for.
We also looked at
samples from Iceland,
very similar type of samples.
Again, the high
helium isotope ratios
really shows that
we're looking at rocks
that are from a primitive and
isolated source from subductive
mixing down in the deep mantle.
These samples were
erupted subglacially,
but essentially that's
the same as [INAUDIBLE].
They're under pressure, so it
stops the gas from escaping.
Again, we're looking at
glassy melt inclusions,
so these are some of
the inclusions in here.
If you've noticed the scale on
here, that's 40 microns there.
So that's about a 35 micron
width melt inclusion.
That's about a fifth the
width of a human hair,
and that's one of the big ones.
Because that's why I've taken an
image of it, that's a good one.
So the others are much
smaller than that.
They're really, really
difficult measurements
to make, because that
isn't a water glob
inside, it isn't a liquid
bit of water, it's glass.
It's only got parts per million
of water in the actual glass
and we're looking
at something that's
less than 40 microns across.
So the measurements are
really, really difficult.
Not only that, but the
samples have to be polished,
they have to be prepared.
So how do you do that
without using water,
without using any kind of resin
that doesn't contain hydrogen,
without exposing them
to the atmosphere,
or touching them with your
fingers, or breathing on them?
It took years for us to
perfect the methodology
to be able to make
these measurements.
It helps if you've
got a big machine.
Which in Hawaii
we have something
called the Cameca 1280
ims ion-microprobe.
It's this thing.
It's the size of a
big room like this.
It makes a variation
of different noises.
And there are three people that
permanently run this thing.
It has a very high vacuum
sample chamber here which
we put the samples in.
They're stored in a
vacuum oven at 60 degrees
C to stop hydrogen
getting anywhere
near the surface of the sample.
We then put them at
very high vacuum in here
and we bombard them
with cesium ions.
So a beam of charged
particles hits the surface
and makes these little pits over
what were the melt inclusions.
The pits are about one
micron depth in size,
so you're not really
destroying much of the sample.
And you make an aerosol
which then goes through here
into the mass
spectrometer and tells you
how much hydrogen you've got
versus how much deuterium
you have.
I should mention we also
measured oxygen isotopes just
to be able to tell
whether we did have
any contamination from things
like rainwater, from things
like mixing as the samples
came up through the crust,
did they dissolve any
kind of crystal rock
into the sample which would
contaminate our hydrogen
signature.
If you imagine you
have some lava that
dissolves a lot of sediment
that's very water rich,
you don't want
that in your sample
because it's going to
contaminate the results.
So if I start with
this graph, actually,
you can see our Icelandic
samples the points are in gray,
the Baffin Island
samples are in red,
and we compare them to
some previous Hawaiian data
which is this green point here.
Two of the Icelandic samples
showed altered oceanic crust
contaminant.
So immediately we
discounted these samples.
So we've got delta D. Again,
Vienna Standard Mean Ocean
Water is zero,
anything above that
is deuterium rich
compared to ocean water,
anything below is more rich in
the lighter hydrogen isotope.
All our samples, apart from
these Icelandic samples
which are contaminated, plotted
below Vienna Standard Mean
Ocean line.
That's not surprising because,
as I had mentioned, normal rock
samples, they have a
negative value anyway.
But this is the region of
the normal rock samples, what
we call MORB, it means
Mid-Ocean Ridge Basalt. So, it's
a typical sample of a
typical mantle basalt.
They plot in this very
narrow region here,
in this orange rectangle,
at around about minus 55
to minus 65.
None of our Baffin
Island samples,
and this one Icelandic sample,
they don't plot in that region.
So they're not
typical mantle samples
according to the DH ratio.
I've just plotted along
with water content here.
Water content is interesting,
because we're also
looking to see how
much water there
is in the mantle in general.
The MORB basalts
have a variation,
so normal basalts have a
variation of water content.
And it goes up to about
0.1 of a weight percent,
so 0.1 percent,
really, of the rock
will be water in the most water
rich normal mantle basalts.
Our samples extend much further
in terms of water content
and have much lower DH ratios.
So this delta D value
here, the lowest
that we measured in a Baffin
Island sample, was minus 218.
That's about-- the
lowest value before that
was these Hawaiian samples at,
I think this one is minus 165.
So we've gone quite a bit
lower than previous samples,
and these samples are even
much lower than normal samples.
So we can definitely say there's
a source in the deep mantle
that has a lot more of
the lighter hydrogen
isotope than Vienna
Standard Mean Ocean Water.
In addition, it's
got more water.
So why would that be?
Well, we came up with
this hypothetical source.
As I mentioned at the
beginning of the talk,
the sun and normal
molecular hydrogen
have a lot of the
lighter hydrogen isotope.
They have a very
negative delta D value.
It's actually at minus 870,
so it's somewhere down here.
So we use that as
our theoretical sort
of end member for our
theoretical deep mantle source.
And we use the water content
of around about 1 weight
percent water.
Because, based on the Hawaiian
lavas, and previous researchers
have determined
that these samples,
their source regions had around
about one weight percent water.
So that source plots
somewhere over here.
None of our material
in the glassy melt
inclusions plots anywhere
near this theoretical,
what we call the
protosolar source, so
a very primitive source.
We get around, at the
lowest values, a 20% value.
So it's 20% this
protosolar source, and 80%
this normal MORB mantle source.
You would expect that
the diagram I showed you
earlier on with the core
mantle boundary and the plume
coming up through thousands
of kilometers of mantle,
you would not expect that
that plume hadn't interacted
in any way with all
of the mantle material
that it was coming through.
It's obviously
interacted quite a bit.
But we do see a 20%
signature of something
that's potentially
quite rare and that
doesn't exist elsewhere on the
surface of the Earth, something
that we don't have
pure samples of.
-What was that 20% one for?
That one?
-This one?
So this is 20% the theoretical
protosolar source here.
-And where did it
come from again?
You said it.
-Oh, this is from Baffin Island.
So the red samples are
from Baffin Island,
and the gray are from Iceland.
So it looks as though,
also, the Icelandic samples
may have been more
degassed, because they
contain less water.
So glacial eruption probably
didn't pressurize quite as much
as the subaqueous eruptions.
I'm sure there's been
degassing in all of them,
but it's the amount
of degassing.
Here you can see they're
quite water poor compared
to the Baffin Island samples.
So maybe they just weren't
under quite enough pressure.
In terms of oxygen
isotopes, something
that we found that we
didn't expect to find
was there's a correlation
between the DH ratio,
the delta D values here, and
the oxygen isotope ratio.
And it seems that--
this is delta 18 O,
it just means
oxygen isotope of 18
over an oxygen isotope
of atomic mass 16.
That's the ratio there.
What we see is an enrichment
in the lighter hydrogen
isotopes, so a more
negative delta D value,
corresponds with a lower delta
18 O value, so an enrichment
in the lighter oxygen isotope.
We don't really
know why this is,
but protosolar things
like the solar wind
are very rich in
oxygen 16 compared
to sources on the Earth.
So this is hinting that
there's something there
that we haven't
quite understood yet.
In terms of the source
of Earth's water,
what does this mean?
We've got a low DH ratio,
we've got lots of the lighter
hydrogen isotope.
What bodies in the solar system
have a similar DH ration?
Well, the, sort of, front
runner at the moment
is the C type asteroids.
These asteroids are
thought to be the parent
body for what are known as
the carbonaceous chondrite
meteorites.
They're quite a common
meteorite group on Earth,
they're known to
contain a lot of water.
Some of them are very clay
rich and they contain up
to 10 weight percent water.
So there's no
problem in us forming
the Earth from 100%
carbonaceous chondrites
and having enough water.
In fact, we'd have way too much.
But it's very unlikely
that the Earth
formed from 100% these
carbonaceous chondrites.
It's more likely that it was
a mixture of different things.
In terms of the DH
ratio, that works.
These C values here that
you see in the orange lines,
this is DH ratio
here, you can see
they plot below Vienna Standard
Mean Ocean Water, which
is this orange Earth line.
Minus 218, which is our
lowest Baffin Island sample,
is around about here.
So they do correspond
to that lower value.
Some of them plot much lower.
This is that protosolar
source that I
was talking about at minus 870.
We can see the comets up here.
Really, they don't have anything
to do with these values.
You cannot get all of Earth's
water from cometary origins
and have the right DH ratios,
even just for the ocean water,
and let alone for what we
found in the deep mantle.
It doesn't work.
Another facet of evidence
that's recently been discovered
is from the eucrite meteorites.
These are meteorites
that are thought
to be from the
asteroid Vesta, which
is present in the main
asteroid belt at the moment.
It's still there, we
sent a mission to it,
we had a look at it.
And we said we've got
these meteorites on Earth,
we've got these spectra from
a remote sensing orbiter,
and it looks like they're
made of the same stuff.
So that was a really
successful mission in saying,
Yes, we definitely got
pieces of Vesta on Earth
and they're known as
the eucrite meteorites.
The interesting thing is
they have the same DH ratio
as the carbonaceous chondrites.
And so it was said
that the eucrites
are formed from the
carbonaceous chondrites.
Now Vesta is interesting because
it's not any normal asteroid.
It's actually, we
think, a remnant
planetesimal from the
beginning of the solar system.
So in the early part
of the solar system
we have smaller
planets that formed
into larger and larger planets
by hitting into each other,
colliding, destroying
each other,
and eventually we end up
with the four rocky planets
that we have today.
There were hundreds
of planetesimals,
and there is now
one that we know
of that's left that didn't get
destroyed, and that's Vesta.
It formed only 20 million
years after the formation
of the solar system-- that
sounds like a long time
to a non-geologist,
but it really isn't.
It's a blink of an eye.
These are some of the oldest
meteorites that we know of,
and they kind of could
be the intermediate stage
between these
carbonaceous chondrites
and the terrestrial planets
like Mars, Earth, Mercury,
and Venus.
So this is a really popular
theory at the moment.
The problem is it
doesn't really work
because based on models
of solar system formation,
the carbonaceous chondrites were
nowhere near where Earth was
forming when it was forming.
This is a diagram
from a 2011 paper
that looked at giant
planet migration.
So these are the giant planets,
the black circles here.
You've got Jupiter the biggest
and the other three behind it.
And you can see
that Jupiter moves
in towards the inner solar
system after about four
million years after the
solar system formed.
Jupiter moves in, Saturn follows
a little bit, the other two
kind of stay where they are.
And what happens in the
inner solar system where
the rocky planets are forming
is you get this huge sort
of chaotic environment.
Jupiter squashes
everything together
and everything goes crazy.
Saturn comes in and
then eventually they
move back out to
their current orbits
and you form the
four rocky planets.
The problem with
this diagram is that
the carbonaceous chondrites
are the blue dots.
They formed in the
outer solar system.
The red dots, which here seem
to be the material that make up
the terrestrial
planets, are what's
known as the
ordinary chondrites,
and they are a very
common meteorite.
They fall to Earth all the time.
If any of you remember
the meteor that
fell over Russia that
landed in the lake,
that was an ordinary chondrite.
And everyone got really excited
and then found it, oh, it's
an ordinary chondrite.
So, they're common
because they are
present in the
inner solar system.
The problem is they don't
have the right DH ratio,
they have a very high DH ratio.
They contain a lot of deuterium.
You can see there are
some blue spots in there,
so there are some
carbonaceous chondrites,
but calculations
show that this is not
anywhere near enough to produce
either the right hydrogen
isotope ratios that will
be low enough for Earth,
or the amount of
water that we think
is present even on the surface,
even for the lowest estimates.
So there's a problem here.
So people started to look
elsewhere and say, OK,
well what other mechanisms
can we think of.
So in 2015 a group at Scripps
actually thought, well,
what about if we just say
we've just got some dust,
one astronomical
unit from the sun.
And there's water
in the cloud, we
know there's water in
the molecular cloud.
How much water will
stick to the dust
particles, or the
olivine grains,
at certain temperatures?
Because it is based
on this assumption
that in a hot environment you
can't stick water to anything
because it is present as gas.
That's not true, it turns out.
And water molecules will
stick to dust particles
at up to 900 Kelvin.
So that's, actually,
hotter, we think,
than the temperature at one
AU when the Earth was forming.
Not only that, but if
there's a lot of water
present and you've got
something like an olivine grain,
it will start to change
to clay material.
It will start to alter in this
very water rich environment.
So you get more water
coming in and coming in.
So, the bottom line of
that is that the entirety
of Earth's water can actually
be delivered during accretion.
You don't need any addition
of water from elsewhere.
Not only will it be
delivered during accretion,
during the formation of
Earth, but it can actually
stick around as well.
You form Earth
and it's very hot.
You have no crust.
You've got this lava world.
But that's only the surface,
most of the water is inside.
So for a water molecule to
get thousands of kilometers
up in the short time period that
it takes for Earth to solidify
at the surface is
actually very difficult.
So the argument here
is that yes, you
will lose a lot of water
because the Earth's hot,
but you're not going
to lose all of it
because there was lots
and lots of it around.
The last slide, what next.
Well, I mentioned
the oxygen isotopes
and when I saw the correlation
that kind of suggested
that the oxygen 16 was very
rich in the samples we measured,
I was kicking myself
because I only
measured two isotopes of oxygen.
I didn't measure oxygen 17,
and oxygen 17 is
the important one
for determining what body each
type of meteorite came from.
So this is a very complicated
graph, but basically anything
that is from Earth
at the moment plots
along this dashed line, the
terrestrial fractionation line.
Anything that is not from
Earth will plot elsewhere
in these ellipses, for
the chondritic meteorites,
this tiny ellipse here for
the Martian meteorites.
Our sample suggests that if
we did measure oxygen 17,
it might not have
plotted on this line.
And that would be an absolute
first for any terrestrial rock.
So now I need to go back to
the big machine in Hawaii
and I need to make
some more measurements.
OK, I think that's it.
Yep.
[APPLAUSE]
-OK, hold your questions.
We have one more speaker
and then after his talk
then we'll have
them come up and you
can ask questions of
both of the speakers.
So our final talk
is by Ben Harden
who is assistant professor
of oceanography at the Sea
Education Association.
I was lucky enough to
get a colleague's cruise
on one of their sailing
vessels a couple years ago.
And he also works as a
researcher at Woods Hole
Oceanographic institute.
His work centers on ocean
currents in the North Atlantic.
And this, again, just by
anecdote is of interest to me
because I teach a course
on navigation and one
of the things that
has fascinated
me is the period when the Norse
settled first Iceland and then
Greenland.
And there is some evidence
that temperatures in the North
Atlantic were warmer, and
there is this critical area
called the Denmark Strait
between Iceland and Greenland
that had to be crossed.
And we know that the
colonies in Greenland
emerged roughly 1000 a.d.
And then got shut
down around 1350,
around the time of
the Little Ice Age.
So this area of
the Denmark Strait
has been fascinating to
me because it's somehow
the source of the world's
largest underwater waterfall,
and has all these strange
currents going on,
and so I have to
hear about this.
So his talk is entitled The
Fate of the Gulf Stream.
So, here's Ben.
[APPLAUSE]
-This afternoon's session should
be dubbed the Brit session,
I think.
Thank you to Lydia
first and foremost.
That was an absolutely
fascinating talk.
And some stuff that I've never
really ever thought about.
This is great.
I think about what happens when
the water, with the water that
we actually have on
our planet right now.
So what I'm going
to do today, I'm
going to talk a little bit about
where the water circulates to
in the North Atlantic.
What are some of the
important processes,
and what are some of
the things that we still
don't know that we need to know
in order to understand how this
might change in the future.
So I like to start
with this image,
just because I like old maps.
This is actually from
1943, it's an army map
of the North Atlantic.
And it shows the
surface circulation
that we find in
the North Atlantic.
I like it because these
lines here are streamlined,
and it basically picks out
some of the really key features
of the circulation around
the North Atlantic.
We have a subtropical
gyre down here
in the Southern portion of
the North Atlantic, which
basically takes water
and circulates it
all the way around.
And then if we go further north
we have a subpolar gyre up
in the Irminger Sea, and
that just takes water
and actually sends
it the other way
around over the southern
coast of Greenland up there.
Right over here on
the Western boundary
is a current you are
probably familiar with.
That's the Gulf Stream.
This is a jet of water
that starts off down here
in the Caribbean region and goes
up the East Coast of the United
States.
If this thing was
a fire hose, it
would be able to fill 10
sports stadia every second.
So it's pumping a
huge amount of water.
And the important thing for
climate is that water's warm.
So as it comes up, it's
actually moving a lot of heat
away from the equator.
The equator gets an excess
of heat from the sun.
The poles get not enough heat.
So the Gulf Stream is really
instrumental in taking
some of that heat and pumping
it northwards in the North
Atlantic.
And the Gulf Stream
sets off on its journey
and it actually
ends up coming out
between these two gyres here.
Some of it gets deflected
around both ways,
but you actually
get about 30% of it
ends up exiting the whole
system and heading up
into the Nordic seas north
of Great Britain there.
I want to pause
briefly and point
out something about physical
oceanographers, of which I
am a member.
And that is we love to
draw arrows on maps.
This is a simulation
where I actually
take some Earth
data from satellites
and plot it up in a real
time image of what's
happening with the currents
in the North Atlantic
at the moment.
And so, as I was
drawing on my map
we had a nice, strong arrow
that was going out here
across towards Northern Europe.
But in reality
what's happening is
we have a meandering
system that's
chucking up little eddies,
and is being kind of
chaotic in its progress.
And if you take it further North
there's a lot of meandering,
there's a lot of
chaotic movement
that's going on in this region.
We do have a drift
of warm water that
comes up from the gulf
stream and ends up
up here in the Nordic seas.
And the question we're
going to ask today
is what happens to that water
once it crosses that boundary
up into the Arctic Ocean.
So, this is the region
that we're going
to be talking about today.
The region that John
was talking about that's
between Greenland and Iceland
here, the Denmark Strait,
this is actually
the area that I'm
going to focus primarily
on today because it's
a really vital region for
the circulation of the North
Atlantic.
What we have is this remaining
30% of the Gulf Stream
comes up into the Nordic seas
as a warm surface current.
And it flows up,
a majority of it,
to the north of Scotland here.
A small sliver of it comes
in around the North coast
of Iceland.
And the great thing about
physical oceanography
is that we can follow
these currents by tagging
their unique fingerprints.
So each current
has a temperature
and it has a
salinity, a saltiness.
And by looking at
those two properties,
we can actually create a
fingerprint for that current.
And then as we
follow it along, we
can actually work
out where it goes.
The important thing
about this current
is that it's very, very
warm as it comes in.
That's the reason why we
have tropical conditions
at the south coast of
Cornwall in the UK.
It's the reason why the most
northerly botanic gardens
in the world is in
Tromso in Norway.
This current is bringing
a lot of heat northwards.
It's vital to the
climates of these regions.
If we didn't have this warm
flow of water coming northwards,
we'd be in a very similar
climatic situation to Labrador
or Alaska in our climate.
So, you know, these are really,
really important inputs of heat
into this region.
So we have this warm water
flowing into this region.
This region here is
called the Nordic seas.
It's basically the gateway
into the Arctic Ocean,
which is up here.
The Arctic Ocean, though,
is an enclosed basin.
There's no real way
out once you go in.
There's a couple of
little gaps, there's
one over here,
the Bering Strait,
and there's some areas through
the archipelago in Canada
that water can eke through,
but not in great quantity.
So, the situation
our warm water's got
is once it comes
in, it can't keep
coming in unless some
water is flowing out.
Otherwise, we're just going
to keep piling, piling,
piling all this water
up in the North,
and it won't be able to do that.
One of the primary ways that we
exchange that warm water that
goes north is with dense water
that's coming back south.
And this what is coming back
south not at the surface,
but deep in the ocean.
It's actually passing
across, conveniently for us
who you want to
measure it, there's
a ridge, an oceanic ridge
that runs between Greenland,
Iceland, the
Faroes, and Scotland
that has some small gaps in it.
This ridge is about six to
1,000 meters deep in the ocean.
It has these small gaps.
One is the Denmark Strait,
there's the Faroe bank channel
over here, and there's a small
one to the east of Iceland
as well.
The Denmark Strait
is the one I'm
going to focus on today because
it's the primary channel.
It is the largest
of the overflows.
It's ultimately the
densest of the overthrows.
It has the largest
contributor to the, kind of,
return flow of water.
And the basic
question that people
have been asking
for quite some time
is how do we take this warm
water that is flowing in
and turn it into that
dense water that's
going to flow back out again?
Basically, as a side
schematic, it looks like this.
We have warm water flowing in.
We need to somehow
convert this warm water
into dense water that can then
go over this ridge and cascade
down to the deep ocean.
This is, as John was
saying, one of the largest
underwater waterfalls
in the world.
It's cascading from
about 600 meters depth
all the way down to
2 and 1/2 kilometers
or further as it
goes back southwards.
Hugely dynamic system.
But it all starts
in how we produce
the dense water, the
deep, dense water
north of the Denmark Strait.
So oceanographers,
physical oceanographers,
have mulled this over
for many decades.
Back in the 80s,
everyone was basically
centered on the idea of OK,
you just send warm water
into that basin.
You hit it with
intense cold winds.
Maybe you form some sea
ice which rejects some salt
into the water.
And eventually that water
just becomes dense enough
in the central basins that it
just sinks and flows back out.
This was challenged in the
1990s by a researcher called
[INAUDIBLE] who proposed
that instead of looking
in the middle of the ocean
here, we should actually
follow the Gulf Stream on its
path and see where it goes.
And she proposed that
actually what's happening
is this Gulf Stream
water, as it comes in,
is just flowing progressively
around the outside
of the Nordic sea.
It's being hit by winds.
Sea ice is being
formed around it.
And basically you just get
colder and saltier all the way
around until
eventually it can sink
along the edge of
the continent here
and flow straight back out.
So we've got like
a pipeline system
now, rather than a
more diffuse system.
If we zoom in to the Denmark
Strait in particular,
this current we call the
East Greenland Current
because it flows on the
east coast of Greenland.
It comes in here,
passes over here,
this is our sill at
600 meters, and then
it's about to cascade down
into the really deep ocean.
And what you can do is
you can go out there
and you can take a
ship across this line
and lower some instrumentation
and look at the fingerprints
of those currents.
And you can really see those
significant fingerprints.
This is a cross-section
of the ocean.
Over here is the
Greenland coast.
This is the shelf.
And this is dropping off into
the middle the Denmark Strait
here.
Everything below
this white line here
is destined to
join the overflow.
And what you can see is
we have temperature on top
here, and salinity
on the bottom here,
is that below that white
line we have this nice blob
of warm, salty water.
It's got a lot denser since
it was in the Gulf Stream,
but really that fingerprint
is still on that current.
We know that it came from
the Gulf Stream water.
And more importantly,
it's flowing out
of the page towards
us, towards the Strait.
Of also note, up
here on the shelf
we have a lot of very, very
cold, very, very fresh water.
And that's the outflow
from the Arctic Ocean.
So the Arctic dumps
a lot of freshwater
into the ocean, which
then flows out as well.
So actually, it's a combined
current. the East Greenland
Current.
We have a deep, dense component
that came from the Gulf Stream
originally, and then we have
this fresh surface outflow
which is joining
it at the surface.
So everything was great,
everything was hunky dory
back in the 1990s.
We knew where this
water was coming from.
We knew how the Denmark
Strait got it's water.
We knew where the key regions
were to focus on in order
to understand how
the water might
be changed under future
climate change [INAUDIBLE].
Bingo.
2000s came, some
pesky Icelanders
discovered a brand new
current that no one had ever
seen before flowing on the
North coast of Iceland.
This is not an
uncommon occurrence
to discover currents
in this region.
They're very, very
small in scale
compared to the Gulf Stream
because of rotational effects
as you get higher up
towards the poles.
But this is a brand
new discovery,
and this was also bringing
dense water towards the Strait,
but it wasn't coming from the
same direction as the East
Greenland Current.
It was coming from around
the corner, around the coast
of Iceland over here.
They called it the
North Icelandic Jet,
and if you expand
that cross-section
that I showed originally,
all the way out over here,
this is Iceland now over
here, you can see roughly
where this dashed
line is here we
got a demarcation from this
warm, salty overflow water that
was going to be in the
East Greenland Current
and you suddenly jump to a much
fresher, much colder product.
A fingerprint that was
distinctly different
from the Gulf
Stream, and we needed
to know where that
was coming from.
Importantly, again, it's coming
out of the page towards us.
It's flowing this
way towards the cell.
Of note, also, up here we've
got some very warm, salty water.
That's that little eking
stream of warm water
we had flowing in round
the top of Iceland.
So we've got that warm
water coming directly
in from the Gulf Stream
as well in that region.
So that's basically the
situation as we understood it.
We had a very well
known source of water,
and all of a sudden we had
this mysterious current that
was coming from a new
direction and we didn't
know where it's coming from.
And so that's significant,
looking at those two
dense pathways, because if we
don't know where that water is
coming from, we don't know
what formation regions are
going to be important.
If we change the
wind conditions,
if we change freshwater
inputs, if we change sea ice
distributions, how
would that affect
the water that's being
produced that then feeds in?
How would that then
affect how much water can
flow north in the Gulf Stream?
The reason we've only recently
discovered these pathways
and been asking
these questions is
that this is a pretty
perilous place to visit.
As a context to the
video I'm about the show,
I did my undergraduate
in physics
and my master's in physics.
I dabbled in particle physics
and astrophysics for a while
before deciding that I
wanted to do something
more environmental in my focus.
And so I signed up
for a PhD Program
at the University of East Anglia
where my supervisor promptly
sent me to sea.
And said go to sea,
there's a research vessel
that's going to be out
in the Denmark Strait,
you're going to study
the wind conditions
around the coast of
Greenland and your thesis
is all going to be about
extreme wind events.
I was like, this is fine.
I can do this.
He said, go stand out on
the back of the vessel
and launch meter wide helium
balloons into the storm.
I've got this on mute
because you don't
want to hear the commentary.
-How big is that wave?
-Oh, it's, it was at least
as high as the bridge,
if not more.
This is the research
vessel in [INAUDIBLE].
And so my job during
this first installment
of my oceanography career was
to go out and try and stand
on the back of that ship to
launch a weather balloon.
-Were you tied in?
-Just about, yeah.
It was an exhilarating
experience,
but the interesting--
within the context
of this interdisciplinary
notion that John
was talking about in
the introduction, one
of the great things
about this region
is there's so much influence
of the atmosphere on the ocean.
This is how I got
interested in oceanography
in the first place was seeing
these winds and saying,
wow, you know, this is
a dynamic environment.
I wonder what these winds
are doing to the ocean.
So it's very hard to
go to this region.
You go out there in these
ships, you try and take
these measurements,
and we only actually
have four snapshots
across this current system
in eight years of asking.
So you've really only got
this little tiny look at it.
And the problem with it
is that every time you
go out with the ship the
current system looks different.
You want to measure how much
water is coming from each place
if you want to know how
much each is contributing
to the overflow.
2004 the East Greenland
Current, 85% of the overflow.
Great, cool, we've
got this sorted.
We don't need to worry about
the North Icelandic Jet.
2012, oh heck, it's
gone the other way.
60% of it's in the
North Icelandic Jet.
So we've got a problem here.
We don't know whether this
is-- is this a seasonal thing?
Because we actually only
go out in the summer
to measure these things.
What's even happening
in the winter time?
Is this, if we went out a week
later would it be different?
If we went out a year later?
You know, is this
a decadal trend?
Or is this something that's
happening very quickly?
And we really don't have a
way of doing that if we just
keep going out with
ships one by one
to try and measure
these systems.
So the way that we
solved the problem
is kind of a technological
solution, which
is to go out with a
series of moorings
across the whole current system.
So a mooring, an
oceanographic mooring,
is basically a big
anchor that sits
on the sea floor with
a wire that comes up
to a very buoyant float.
We keep our floats about
100 meters below the surface
because there's a lot of
icebergs in the region,
there's a lot of
fishing vessels that
will come along and smash them.
We lose a lot of moorings
in this region because
of those kind of activities.
So we have to be
a little careful,
and the old
oceanography adage is
you don't put something
into the water
that you're expecting
to get back.
You have to be a little bit
realistic about this process.
And I thought I'd
just say a little bit
about how we deploy
them, because I
think it's kind of fascinating.
You have to take the
ship back out there
to put these things in.
And the way that you put them
in is you kind of go backwards.
This is, again, the [INAUDIBLE].
This is a much nicer day
in the Denmark Strait.
We got very lucky on
this particular cruise.
And the idea is you're
on the back of the ship
and you put it in backwards.
You put the float in
first, the top float.
Put that in the
water, release it,
and you've got the wire now
attached to the bottom of it,
right.
And you now steam
away from that and you
start laying out
your wire, you start
adding the instrumentation
one by one,
and you just keep
spooling it out.
And eventually you end up with
the anchor that goes over last.
So you lower the anchor in,
it's just a big chunk of steel.
Then when you get to exactly
the right point in the ocean
where you want to drop it
you trigger the release,
the anchor drops,
buoys go down, and then
that top float comes
water skiing towards you
as it's being dragged
down underneath the water.
And so then you
leave them there.
We actually left 12 of
them across the whole thing
between Iceland and Greenland.
You leave them there for
a year, you go back home,
you go back to
your regular life,
and you try not to think
about it because there's
no point worrying about it.
You might go out next
year and discover
that every single one of
them has been destroyed,
or taken away somewhere else.
You have to do the best you can
to put that out of your mind.
And then you do go
out a year later
to find out whether these
things are still there,
and one of the things about
going to pick these moorings up
is that they're
below the surface
and you can't see
them from the boat.
So you have to find
them electronically,
and you have to, using a fish
finder, or something like that,
go back to the place
where you left them.
And because radio waves travel
really badly through the water,
you can't just send
a radio signal out
to say, hey, release it.
You actually have to use sound,
sound waves, in the water.
And so what you do is
you go back out again
on a different ship, also a nice
day off the coast of Greenland.
And this is a little
speaker, basically,
that sends out sound
waves into the water
over the side of the ship.
And we send a coded
series of pings which
the anchor is listening for.
And if we send the right
combination at the right code,
basically, to the
anchor, it's going
to release its
grip on the anchor
and then the whole thing's going
to float up to the surface.
But you don't know where
it's going to come up.
And everyone looks
at the ocean, and you
don't know whether it's
actually going to show up.
And all of a sudden it pings
up onto the surface there.
Now it's floating around and
you have to go pick it up
with your ship.
Those are the good
days when that happens.
The bad days can be when you
send a ping out it says, OK,
I've released, and then nothing
shows up at the surface.
And then you have to go
out with-- you actually
put a long grappling
hook out behind the ship
and just go around, and
round, and round in the ocean
hoping you're going
to grab something.
And then you drive away, hoping
it's going to kind of drag
the whole thing with it.
So we actually got really,
really lucky on this trip.
All 12 of them came back.
This is not something that
happens very regularly.
So we've actually been able to
now look at the whole Strait
wide circulation in
some detail, and not
just through four snapshots
of what the current's doing.
We now have 1008 snapshots
over the course of a year.
And so we can do things that we
haven't been able to do before,
like produce an average
hydrographic section,
an average temperature and
salinity across the strait.
And this looks largely
similar to some
of the stuff we've seen before.
Again, Greenland on
the left, Iceland
on the right, this white line
is that line that's important.
Everything below that is going
to join the overflow, that's
the dense water that's
going to go head back South.
Up on the surface,
on the left here, we
have that cold
fresh surface water
from the Arctic pouring out.
That's all the melt water.
Over right here that's
the warmer, saltier waters
coming in from the Atlantic
Ocean surface, those two
surface currents.
And then deeper down, below
that density interface,
we have warm, salty water from
the East Greenland Current,
and then, again, colder,
fresher water over
on the Iceland side from
the North Icelandic jets.
We have, again, seen
these fingerprints now
over the course
of the whole year.
So we can start to say, hey,
we think the North Icelandic
Jet's actually going to be an
important thing all year round,
it's not necessarily
just a summertime thing.
We even went further
and were able to compare
those fingerprints of those
two currents to historic data
from upstream of
the Denmark Strait.
So this is our mooring array
here across the strait.
This is one mooring over here
in the East Greenland Current,
and one over here in
the North Icelandic Jet.
And we can actually compare the
fingerprints between these two
regions, and they
match up really well.
So we've actually been
able to show not just
that we have two
different kind of waters,
but they actually come
from two different places
along the coast.
I wanted to show you
earlier about the fact
that we love drawing
arrows on maps
to point out where the
currents are going from and to.
The reality, again, is that
we can't quite be so specific.
This is a video of the
current velocities,
the speed of the currents
coming through the red.
And Greenland on the left,
Iceland on the right.
Red colors mean the
current's coming towards us,
and blue colors mean the
current's heading away from us.
And so at times it
looks kind of stable.
But then after a while
it starts to cascade.
And you get blobs of
blue, and blobs of red,
and they shift from
one side to the other
when things start coming in
and going out of the region.
And this is just to
exemplify that we
love drawing these arrows that
point currents in singular
directions, but in reality
we have a very dynamic system
that's eddying and distorting
throughout the year.
So, how can we use this
kind of information
to actually say how much water
is coming from each direction
if it's so dynamic?
And we use those
fingerprints, in general,
to be able to do this.
Say, this is one snapshot
of the current at one time.
Here's a current
coming out of the page,
here's another current
over here, a little tiny
one, that's up here.
And here is our
temperature and salinity.
And then, again, you can
see those same fingerprints,
warm, salty over
here, and then colder
and fresher over on that side.
And we can basically draw a line
at every time, every snapshot
that we have that divides the
currents between currents that
are carrying the East Greenland
Current water, these two here,
and currents that are carrying
North Icelandic Jet water,
this little current up here.
So we can actually use the
data about the fingerprints
to divide these currents
up into what kind of water
they're bringing.
And so the results of that
are shown in this figure.
It's a time series that
shows the percentage
from the Greenland side, the
percentage of East Greenland
Current that's in our array.
And so over here
would be entirely
East Greenland Current, over
here would be entirely North
Icelandic Jet.
So the light line is what's
happening every single eight
hours, the dark line is a
smoothed average over 30 days.
And so what we can see
is, actually, this current
is extremely dynamic.
It's jumping from 100%
East Greenland Current
to 100% North
Icelandic Jet at times.
It's going back
and forth, someone
is turning the
faucet on, and off,
and on, and off, on different
sides of this Strait
to bring water through.
You can also see that there's
some kind of seasonality
as well, maybe in the wintertime
the East Greenland Current
brings more water.
Maybe the North Icelandic
Jet's a bigger player
in the summertime when we've
seen it before in our, kind of,
snapshots.
So there's much to
learn from this.
The simplest thing we can
do is take an average.
It's the first time we're
able to do this and actually
robustly say how much water's
coming from each direction,
and about 70% of it's coming
from the East Greenland
Current and 30% is coming
from the North Icelandic Jet.
So we now have a
pretty good image
of the importance of these
two different branches.
And we now know that
the North Icelandic
Jet is something that's
there all year round,
and it brings a significant
quantity of water.
The question now is
where does it come from?
And that's still
an open question.
We don't really know.
One hypothesis is that that
warm water that actually comes
in north of Iceland, it
kind of spreads out here
into the Iceland Sea, and
it's subject to very, very
cold intense winter conditions,
and it sinks directly here
and flows directly back
towards the Strait.
The reason we think that
is because, actually, we've
followed the North
Icelandic Jet upstream
and followed that fingerprint.
It eventually just
peters out around here.
Kind of comes from nowhere.
But it was also, kind of,
comes from a very large body
of dense water.
So we think there's
a kind of smoking gun
there about where
that water is formed.
But we don't know.
The next big project is heading
out into the Iceland Sea
to work out whether we can find
exactly where that water is
coming from.
Taking a step out
again, you know,
now we kind of have this
slightly more sophisticated
picture of where the overflow
water is coming from.
This region here
in the Iceland Sea
could be important, this region
here where making dense water
could be important.
There are also
other possibilities,
things that we may not
have thought about yet
because we haven't been able
to go out there and measure it
often enough.
But this all kind of brings
us back to the central point
is that if we can't make this
dense water somewhere, then
we can't bring the
warm water northwards.
And that's going to change the
climate of the Northern Europe
regions.
So, some key questions
going forward.
You know, where is this
North Icelandic Jet formed?
How is it formed and
how often is it formed?
Do the two branches
compensate for each other?
If, under some
climate scenario, we
have an increase in wind
in a particular area,
sea ice retreated
back somewhere,
would one of these
currents be able to pick up
the slack from the other one
if the other one was weakening?
Would the other one be
able to intensify in order
to pick up the slack?
It's an open question.
And how sensitive
is the whole system?
We know in the past that
this whole thermohaline,
this whole circulation,
the North Atlantic
shut down various glacial
periods in the past.
Is that something that could
happen under climate change
scenarios, or is the
system robust enough
under the kind of
changes that it
will see to actually be
able to sustain itself
and be able to keep bringing
this warm water northwards?
I turn to this picture.
We've been asking the question
of how this warm water flows
North, and it's because we can
exchange with this deep water
that flows South.
And as it cascades down
to 2000, 3000 meters,
it makes it's way
southwards and it hugs
the east coast of the states.
It actually ends up
directly underneath where
it started in the Gulf Stream.
So it kind of goes
nowhere eventually,
it just gets deeper.
And ends up heading all the way
down southwards past Brazil.
And, you know, there's
a kind of couple
of things I wanted to say about
this larger scale circulation.
Was that there's been
some effort for a while
to actually monitor that
large scale circulation down
off the coast of Florida.
A large mooring
array out here called
the rapid array which is trying
to measure the warm water
outflow and the
cold water inflow
and try to make some estimates
of how robust the system is,
how the heat exchange is
actually changing over time.
And lest we forget this whole
thing is tied into a larger
system that goes planet wide.
We've been talking
about this warm water
outflow, the cold water
exchange coming back South.
But this whole thing is
tied into a complex series
of currents that extend
around the globe.
How could one, how could
changes in one of these branches
impact onwards throughout
that entire system.
So that's the, kind of, thought
I wanted to leave you on today.
Thank you very much
for having me speak.
It's been a pleasure.
[APPLAUSE]
-So Lydia, can you come
join Andrew at the table?
And entertain questions?
So there's a microphone in
the back, so other questions
from the audience.
Go ahead.
-Can we start with
your questions?
-Start with my question?
Well, OK, well the first
question is for Lydia
and it's just going to reveal
that I'm a physics nerd,
but at least I'm
in good company.
What is the ion beam that you
use to extract the isotopes?
I mean, I'm just trying
to picture what you do.
You scan it for
these little pockets,
and then you find
the pocket, and then
you have to be able to direct
this tiny, really small beam?
-Yeah.
It's cesium ions that we use.
-OK.
-So, first of all what we
do is we put the samples
in the electron microscope
to actually take pictures
of those glass pockets.
So that's kind of
our reconnaissance.
And when we find
them, the problem
is the ion microprobe,
actually, is
a really sophisticated machine.
But the imaging system is
actually a really old, like,
1980 CCD TV camera.
So all you can see on
the surface is cracks.
And the sample is
coated in carbon,
so you can't see any of
that detail on that image.
You can't see at all.
All you can see is the cracks.
So you have to, kind of, have a
map of the cracks in your mind.
And then go, OK, let's move
a little bit leftwards,
a little bit.
And then you make the pit.
Then you put it back in
the electron microscope
and you say, damn, I missed it.
So it takes a long
time to actually,
sort of, work around how
to navigate in the system.
And then make sure
that you've hit--
the worst is when you half
hit, because if you half
hit you've destroyed the sample,
but you haven't got any data.
-That reminds me of this
t-shirt my son got me
which is stand back,
I'm doing science.
OK, a question here
from the audience?
-Yeah, this is a
question for Lydia.
Is this on?
Hello?
-Yeah.
-OK, and this is a
very naive question.
But my curiosity, or my
need to have it answered,
is greater than
my embarrassment.
So I'm going to ask it
anyway, because I've
wondered about it for a while.
Now, you gave us a criterion
by which we could possibly
determine whether water on
Earth was produced coevally
with the Earth, or
whether it came later
from outside the Earth
extraterrestrially.
And that leads to
my question which
is, what does it
mean to say, when we
say we're running out of water?
I mean, does it, it just
means to say that water
is becoming less accessible?
Like they say the
aquifers are empty.
But the water's going
somewhere, right?
-Yes.
-It's not being
desynthesized, or whatever.
It's not being analyzed into
oxygen and hydrogen, right?
-No.
Apart from the small
amount that we do actually
lose all the time from
the upper atmosphere--
-It goes out into outer space.
-That is lost to space.
But in terms of our reservoirs
and aquifers on the surface,
it's us that's
using the water up.
And it is becoming less
accessible, it's just that--
-But it's just going
somewhere else, right?
-Yeah.
-It's not going to
the rocks, right?
I mean, we don't have conditions
in which it could, or.
-It can if you talk
about at plate margins,
you have lots of ocean
water and sediment.
But that, that's been
happening all the time.
I think the deep water aquifers,
it's because we're using it up
and we're pumping it
out into the oceans,
into the river system.
So it's being removed
from the land,
and it's being pumped
into the oceans.
And then going elsewhere.
Because some of
these systems-- I
think there was a paper
a few years ago that
talked about a water aquifer
underneath North America that's
actually 1.2 billion years old.
-That's the Ogallala, that's
what I'm talking about.
They say it's emptying
out, it's almost empty now.
-Really?
-Because the California farms
are using so much water.
-The Oklahoma farms.
It's under Oklahoma.
The Ogallala is.
-So it doesn't take that much--
-But it's agriculture
that's using it.
--human activity to destroy
things that have been around
for billions of years.
-OK, thank you.
-There was a question back here.
-Hi, this is for the gentleman.
I'm wondering if you
have any more picture
of those underwater waterfalls.
Like, I'm kind of curious.
-Yeah, it's a little hard.
You've got water
falling through water,
so it's not actually something
you can take a picture of.
We know that they exist because
you can go down and measure
the speed of the water.
And you know that the water
above it's largely stagnant,
and then this
layer on the bottom
is sliding down
to the deep water.
But we're talking about
ocean currents, which
aren't necessarily falling
at the rate of water
from a waterfall.
Typically these currents,
at their strongest velocity,
is maybe moving, upstream
of the Strait, maybe 10,
20 centimeters a second.
Actually, in the
overflow itself,
you might get up to
like a meter a second,
or something like that.
The Gulf Stream's a
particularly fast one,
that can go at least
a meter a second.
But, yeah, it's a little
hard to visualize explicitly.
You kind of have to-- with
all of physical oceanography,
I think part of the beauty
of it, a friend of mine
said this, was that you
can't see below the waves,
and so a lot of
what we have to do
is throw our imaginations
down into the deep
to see these things.
-Is it the same thing that's
happening in the Bermuda
Triangle, or is
that something else?
-I don't know specifically
about the Bermuda Triangle's
specific oceanography,
so I don't know.
-That's where the
airplanes disappear.
-It's where the airplanes
disappear, I do know that.
But I think that's
outside the purview
of physical oceanography.
-Question, we have two here.
I guess we'll work
our way forward.
-Also a question for Ben.
You were talking a
little bit about how
what you're looking
at specifically
is related to global
ocean circulation.
And I was wondering,
thinking about, like,
North Atlantic deep water
formation, and stuff like that.
Looking forwards
with climate change,
what do you know or think
about possible changes
in that circulation and whether
the specific currents you're
looking at could
have some effect,
and how do they change too?
-Yeah, absolutely.
We know from the geological
record that in the past
that circulation has
largely shut off,
or it has become
shallower, or it
has moved to a different
part the North Atlantic,
all of which would
affect how much heat we
can get northwards.
One of the major concerns
in the climate change
is melting of the
Greenland ice sheet.
You melt more fresh
water, you dump
that out into the ocean,
and all of a sudden
you've got this fresh, really
light cap on the water that
is really hard for
the winds to cool
down enough to make it sink.
So you're basically shutting
off, and making little cap
on the surface which shuts off
this dense water formation.
It's not entirely clear
if that is happening
or will be important.
As I was showing, a
lot of that fresh water
is flushed out along
the shelf of Greenland.
It's going to be
important to know
if we can get that fresh
water off the shelf
and into the open ocean regions
where this dense water is
being formed.
That's going to be important.
Another thing is if we
have retreating sea ice.
The edge of the sea ice is often
where a lot of the dense water
is made because you have
these winds coming off
the edge of it, they're very
cold and they're very dry.
So you can take both moisture
and heat out, both of which
make the water denser.
And so the sea
ice edge positions
are kind of important
parameter in knowing
where the dense water is
going to form, specifically.
So if that sea ice keeps
retreating or changing
its positions, it may change
where we form the deep water.
Just as, you know, what
we've seen currently
there's been no evidence so
far, no categoric evidence
that we've seen a
slowdown in that system.
But we also know that it
has happened in the past
and it could happen again.
And we have lots of hypothesis
for how it might change.
-My question is for Lydia.
One of the really
mind blowing things
that has come to my attention
as we've started here
at the Institute to think about
our year focused on oceans
is the question
that you addressed,
where do oceans come from?
Because at first I thought
I've never thought about that,
that's really interesting.
And then the next
question becomes, well,
how the heck are you ever
going to answer that question?
And so you've really had this
really amazing presentation
of where your research and
the analysis of your materials
is leading you.
But I really appreciated you
showing that complex machine,
because it really puts
those of us who are not
in the lab in your
kind of world about,
you can't just dream this up,
and it's not just a theory.
It's a tested something,
but how do we test it?
And I'm wondering, if that
machine has been so important
to, kind of, advancing
some of the understanding
that you're making,
can you help us
think through what we should
be looking for as that machine
evolves?
Or as other machines, and,
I guess, a lot of us in town
here are reflecting
on the breakthrough
with LIGO and the way that
that machine, and the machine
structure, helped
to really catalyze
a new way of
understanding space.
-Yeah.
-Thank you.
-It definitely has really, sort
of, revolutionized the analysis
of-- that particular machine--
the analysis of chemistry
in meteorites in
particular, I think.
Because 10 years ago we
didn't know that the moon
had any water at all.
And it was only
through the analysis
of Apollo samples on a
similar machine like this one
that we found there is
actually water in there,
but it's trapped within
the minerals in the rock.
People just kind of
assumed that there's
no water in lunar samples.
And when I was doing my PhD
I asked this question-- I did
my PhD on Apollo
samples-- I asked
this question of my supervisor.
I said, has anyone
actually really measured
the water content
of Apollo rocks?
And he said there's no
need to because there
isn't any water in them.
And I just kind of went away
and thought, OK, well he
knows what he's talking about.
And it was literally
six months later
that all this work was published
and he sent me an apology email
before I even read
the journals online.
He just sent me--
I opened my inbox
and he said, Lydia,
I'm so sorry.
And I thought, what's
he apologizing for?
And then I went on
the science website
and I thought, OK, I was right.
But I would have
been too late anyway.
But it is true not
only for hydrogen,
which we couldn't measure
10 years ago because it's
such a difficult
element to measure,
but for the oxygen
graph that I showed,
that's all ion microprobe work.
So, that kind of
graph determined
that Martian meteorites
are from Mars,
we can prove that the
moon and the Earth
formed from the giant
impact through that data,
and they're developing
all the time.
And all the time they're
getting to the point
where we can measure something
a little bit smaller,
with a little bit
less content in there,
a little bit less abundant,
so, parts per billion of things
now.
And it really does tell
you from something so tiny
you can work out how
the solar system formed,
which is fascinating.
-So there'll be more of those
kind of incremental discoveries
that lead us to [INAUDIBLE]
-I think so, yeah.
I think it is a technological
advancement, really.
An explosion.
-You also have to have somebody
who's going to ask a question,
or at least be willing to
ask the question, right.
-Yeah.
-If you don't have a
person asking the question,
all the machinery in the
world isn't going to help you.
-True.
-I just want to follow the last
question, any possible to use
laser ablation?
Much cheaper, much simple.
And I know people have been
using for oxygen to do that,
because this is much
cheaper way and also
much simple instrumentation.
-For oxygen?
-Laser ablation.
Yes, so laser ablation
is great for looking
at different isotopes of things
if you want to make a larger
hole in your sample.
But it is, it's
getting to the point
where the spot size is
about 20 microns now,
the smallest, I think,
for laser ablation.
-It's true.
-But that's still too large for
the samples that I looked at.
The actual spot size on my
sample was around 8 microns.
And that was on the,
they were really
on the limit of how large
those inclusions were.
Because we didn't want to
get any of the material
from the surrounding
olivine in there.
So we wanted to hit the
middle of the samples.
But laser ablation
is definitely,
it's coming to the point
where, you're right,
it's much cheaper,
it's much smaller,
and you can measure more
than one element a time.
You can get the whole spectrum
of elements at the same time.
The problem is for hydrogen you
can't use it because hydrogen
is so volatile.
It doesn't have the
high vacuum chamber
that the ion microprobe has.
And also, it doesn't
have the resolution
that you can tell between,
for example, deuterium
has an atomic mass of two, but
so does molecular hydrogen.
So you need that huge
electromagnet to separate out
the different atomic masses.
So laser ablation at the moment
can't do that I don't think.
-And I have one more question.
I assume your sample
all from MORB, right?
It's not from [INAUDIBLE] or--
-It's from where, sorry?
-From MORB.
-Mid-ocean ridge basalt.
-Oh, right, right, right.
-Because those is,
they have water
circulated, subduction zone.
It's not true for mantle water.
-Yeah, I didn't measure
the MORB samples.
They're samples that were
standard samples that
had been measured
elsewhere that I just
used as standard samples.
The paper that really
focused on those,
I forget, actually, the name of
the author who measured them.
But that was quite a
recent paper as well.
I'm not sure where they
got their samples from.
-But I assume is from
mid-ocean ridge basalt,
otherwise it's not
direct from mantle.
-It's from the surface, yeah.
It will be from the surface.
It's not from a
deep mantle sample.
But I think they
are fresh samples,
so they're actually quite
fresh pillow lava samples,
so they're not contaminated
by things like sea water.
You can measure, for example,
the chlorine and potassium
isotope ratio of the
glass in the sample
will tell you whether
things like ocean water
have affected the
chemistry of the rock.
So you avoid any kind of
contamination from seawater.
-Yeah, that's true if
your rock sample coming
from [INAUDIBLE] or
[INAUDIBLE], those samples
come from subduction
zone and there's
water circulated from seawater.
-For the MORB samples.
Yeah.
-Yeah, and I also
heard you mention
there's not plate
tectonics on other planet.
Is this your--
-No, I said there's--
-Because there are people
now study plate tectonic
on other planet.
-There's no plate tectonics
on any other planet.
On Mars there is abortive, kind
of, abortive plate tectonics.
So, it kind of started
to begin, but it
didn't break through the crust.
It's a wrinkling of the crust.
But there's no evidence
that it actually
went down into the mantle
and any kind of circulation
started.
And I think that's because
Mars didn't have enough water.
So, it had enough
water early on,
but I don't think it
quite had enough water
to lubricate the system and
get full blown plate tectonics.
Venus doesn't have
any plate tectonics,
and Mercury doesn't have
any plate tectonics.
There's no plate tectonics
on any asteroid or body
that we know of.
But if there is a planet around
another sun somewhere that
has a lot of water,
there's no reason
why there couldn't be plate
tectonics on that planet
as far as I know.
-OK, thank you.
We have another question for--
-We should go to someone else.
Try to spread around
the-- spread it around.
-I have a question for you Ben.
I'm interested in
microbial life in the sea.
And the express trains
that you described
are really interesting
for thinking
about the flow of microbial
life within the ocean.
And I thought at one point you
said that the Arctic Basin was,
like, a closed system,
and then that these things
flow in and maybe flow out.
But then I thought you were
suggesting that now maybe you
think the currents
don't go that far?
-They do.
I presented a, kind of, a
little simplified picture
of what was going on out there.
The thing about the
Arctic is, for the kind
of scales of current to warm
inflow, and these dense water
outflows, the
sub-Arctic Nordic Seas
is the kind of key
exchange region.
Some of this Gulf Stream water
does go into the Arctic Ocean.
And, actually,
once it gets there,
it kind of dives down
below the freshwater.
So it's actually subsurface.
It's, kind of, 100, 200 meters
down in the Arctic Ocean.
So, if you go into the Arctic
and drill through the ice
and look down, you end
up with fresh water
on top of salty, warm
water, and then it goes down
to cold at the bottom.
So, yeah, it does enter.
And there is fresher
water that flows out
through the Canadian
archipelago, much shallower,
and out through the--
most of the water
comes in through the
Bering Strait, actually,
to the Arctic.
-And do the-- does a
microbiologist ever,
like, say to you,
while you're out there,
can you collect a
few samples for us?
-Absolutely.
I was involved in a
project up in the Chukchi
Sea just north west of Alaska, a
very shallow sea, 50 meter sea.
And the whole project
was around joining
the dots between the physics,
the sea ice dynamics,
and the biology of the region.
So we had teams looking at
how the currents were bringing
nutrients into the region,
how the ice was actually now
becoming so thin that light
can actually penetrate through
and so maybe
phytoplankton can start
to bloom underneath the ice
before people had previously
thought it was
possible up there.
So, yeah, again, back to
the interdisciplinary nature
of especially oceanography,
all of the key discoveries
we're going to make are at the
boundaries between physics,
biology, chemistry, geology, ice
dynamics, those kind of things.
-I've got a question up here.
-Hi, my question is for Ben.
And it's on the flip
side of climate change.
So the question is, is there
anybody even tentatively
thinking about ocean currents
and temperature gradients
as potential sources of energy?
-Yeah, I think there
is some thoughts.
I don't know specifics
on this, but I
have heard people discuss a
possibility of using turbines
on ocean currents.
I'm not sure how fruitful
it's going to be.
I know that you can actually,
technically, theoretically
extract energy from the
thermal gradient in the ocean,
but I don't think people
are thinking about this
on a really big scale.
I think we have some much
better, practical options
on land and in coastal
environments where
we have a lot of readily
available energy.
-Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
-OK
-In your talk you
gave us a criterion
to determine when water came
into the Earth's system.
Wouldn't there be another
way of looking at the problem
and answering it which is,
when and where did conditions
obtain for the synthesis of
water from oxygen and hydrogen?
-Yes, so I mentioned about the
molecular cloud earlier on.
So astronomers, which
I am not an astronomer,
they assure me that there was
water in the molecular cloud
before the sun formed.
So that cloud of dust and gas
contained molecules of water.
So we don't need to wait
for things to cool down
after the sun's formation for
the oxygen and the hydrogen
to come together to form
water, it's already there.
It's immediately available.
And the Earth doesn't, it's
not one of the first planets
to form.
So I showed that graph with
the giant planets moving in,
Jupiter begins to
form first, then
Saturn, then Uranus and
Neptune form after that.
And it's only once
those giant planets
are formed, around four
or five million years
after the solar system formed,
that they begin to migrate in.
And then you get the terrestrial
rocky planets forming.
So they're actually
quite late comers
in terms of solar
system formation,
it's kind of the last
big bodies that form.
So you'd expect that things
had kind of settled down
a little bit in terms of oxygen
and molecules forming together.
You've already got solids in
the solar system by that point.
-OK so now it's time
for our reception.
So I'd like to thank
all of the speakers.